[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge allegiance
Oh God make speed to save us O Lord make
haste to help us glory be to the Father
and to the Son and to the Holy Spirit as
it was in the beginning is now and ever
shall be world without end amen praise
the Lord the Lord's name be praised
a reading of the 19th psalm the heavens
declare the glory of God and the
firmament shows his handiwork
one day speaks to another and one night
gives knowledge to another there is
neither speech nor language and their
voices are not heard but their sound has
gone out into all the lands and their
words to the end of the world and then
he has set a tent for the Sun which
comes forth as a bridegroom out of his
chamber and rejoices like a strong man
to run his course it goes forth from the
uttermost parts of the heavens and runs
about to the end of it again and there
is nothing hidden from its heat the law
of the Lord is perfect reviving the soul
the testimony of the Lord is sure and
gives wisdom to the simple the statutes
of the Lord are right and rejoice the
heart the commandment of the Lord is
pure and gives light to the eyes the
fear of the Lord is clean and endures
forever the judgments of the Lord are
true and righteous altogether more to be
desired are they than gold even much
fine gold sweeter also than honey than
the drippings from the honeycomb
moreover by them is your servant taught
and in keeping them there is great
reward
who can tell how often he offends oak
lends me from my secret faults keep your
servant also from presumptuous sins lest
they get the dominion over me so shall I
be undefiled an innocent of great
offence let the words of my mouth and
the meditation of my heart be always
acceptable in your sight O Lord my rock
and my Redeemer
glory be to the Father and to the Son
and to the Holy Spirit as it was in the
beginning is now and ever shall be world
without end amen
here begins the eleventh verse for the
second chapter of Saint Paul's letter to
the Ephesians therefore remember that at
one time you Gentiles in the flesh
called the uncircumcision by what is
called the circumcision which is made in
the flesh by hands remember that you
were at that time separated from Christ
alienated from the Commonwealth of
Israel and strangers the covenants of
promise having no hope and without God
in the world but now in Christ Jesus you
who once were far off had been brought
near by the blood of Christ for he
himself is our peace who has made us
both one and has broken down in his
flesh the dividing wall of hostility by
abolishing the law of Commandments
expressed in ordinances that he might
create create in himself one new man in
place of the two so making peace and
might reconcile us both to God in one
body through the cross thereby killing
the hostility and he came and he
preached peace to you who were far off
and peace to those who were near for
through him we both have access in one
spirit to the Father so then you are no
longer strangers in aliens but you are
fellow citizens with the Saints and
members of the household of God built on
the foundation of the apostles and
prophets Christ Jesus himself being the
cornerstone in whom the whole structure
being joined together grows into a holy
temple in the Lord in him you also are
being built together into a dwelling
place for God by the spirit here ends
the lesson
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the psalmist writes unless the Lord
builds the house those who build it
labor in vain a lesser authority but
still an authority Winston Churchill
writes we shape our buildings and
afterwards they shape us we have cause
to think that this is the largest
classical chapel built in 70 years it's
hard to prove a negative with what one
we can find is the Martin Chapel at
Boston University which was begun in
1920 and finished in 1950 seventy years
the question is not why have we built
this does it call out to you when you
walk in here don't you look up and think
of the ultimate things that could answer
that question is obvious the hard
question is why have others not it's not
expense more expensive builder this is
expensive building more expensive
buildings in this are built every year
on college campuses it's not lack of
example or any old college campus or any
almost any has buildings like this to
look at why did they not emulate them
that would need to be some powerful
cause something to obstruct that
I think it is the most powerful cause I
think it is a turning away from things
that are beautiful
which means necessarily then also things
that are true and things that are good
when the truth and the beauty and good
are gone then of course all reasons the
demand we strive to become good human
beings are gone
and with those reasons disappear the
justification and requirement for human
freedom also go all the precepts that
guide us to the use of our freedom
towards civilization we deserve a plague
has come over the land and that plague
has destroyed many colleges and if it
proceeds to its culmination it will
destroy this one too but that will not
happen we can't really today explain all
of that that I just said it is actually
the purpose of the activity of the
college to explain and understand all
that and that activity goes on intensely
now for 175 years what we can do is SETI
what caused this building it was caused
by several things it is made of matter
Stalin's deal plaster and wood glass and
granite the marble in 12 varieties comes
from and some rose onyx comes from
Carrara in Italy where there quarrying
to build the cathedral repair the
Cathedral of Milan the limestone is from
quarries in an Indiana that supplied
most of the limestone that's in the
nation's capitol in those great old
classical buildings the Granite's come
from Georgia Vermont and Missouri the
Silver Cloud granite on the fountain
outside comes from India the brass cross
appears from Spain
we'd like to publish that old essay by
Leonard read I a pencil
and that's the strongest demonstration
I've ever read of the utter power of the
free market because actually this
building has been produced by the
cooperation of people all over the world
who don't know each other often didn't
know what they were contributing to this
building has been built by people begin
with the designer the architect Arizona
speaks of arts that are architectonic it
comes from the combination of Arc a
beginning a rule or principle and techne
art it's the art that commands it
organizes all the things under it
abstracted from its chief meaning in the
design of buildings it just means ruling
art our architect is and is understood
to be one of the best in the world he is
Duncan strike he was assisted mostly by
many people but mostly by Tom stroke and
Jaime LaCorte his credentials are
sterling he went to Yale and Harvard no
even to where'd you go where'd he go it
doesn't matter where he went he went to
Virginia and Yale
he says his teachers are Thomas
Jefferson and others but his direct
teacher was Alan Greenberg who's one of
the midwives of the revival of classical
architecture in our time a very great
man
Duncan can stand for all the artisans
who worked on this because he's the
first and commanded the others I'd like
Duncan and his colleagues to stand up
please
[Applause]
they caused me to look up and it leads
me to remind you kids sitting on the
front row don't fall off Duncan and I
are having an argument about whether
those rails are too low so far he wins
the fountain outside was designed by
another architect her name is Alice Arn
and she might stand up police
[Applause]
I happen to know that girl and she will
not like it that I made her stand me up
and she really would not like if I
didn't mention the Duncan strike helped
her a lot
the builders built this building they
are Wiegand construction they worked for
us a lot they're awesome they're losing
money on this they would be one of the
biggest contributors to this they
estimated with their usual precision and
skill but nobody's done this in living
memory there's no one alive who's done
this and so they got some things wrong
and that was happened to be things that
are in their responsibility they told us
about it they asked us not to tell the
workmen because they were not because
they didn't want the workmen to change
anything then they mentioned that maybe
they'd hoped to work for the college
again sometime and we told them that
that would have happened anyway the
workmen on the building we're gonna have
a convocation soon in here for the
college and we're going to invite all
the workmen and we're going to put a
plank up with their names on it here and
I will tell you that they work into the
night Marc the supervisor told me that
he had not been to his beloved Lake for
two years they were 60 people working
here on Tuesday of this week and that I
never see them stop work except I come
in and they come to see me and they want
to show me something and they thanked me
for the privilege of helping to build
this they made this building
my colleagues have made this building
working together for 20 years now which
pay way has taken the lead and doing all
of this and so of course this is
responsibility that the East our cage is
not quite finished
John Sweeney's hand is in everything
here on the campus the way we work
together David Whelan Dianne Phillip
Mike honour several others we sat for
hours with Duncan they were delightful
hours - Duncan is a very quick and
intelligent and also stubborn and the
plan emerged from those meetings and the
building would be different without them
all of you built this building begin
with Jack and Joe Bevin Joe said to me
she in a providential an embarrassing
thing she saw the little chapel that she
calls a wine cellar now that was serving
as a chapel here College has always had
a chapel by the way there used to be one
up in the top of central hall it's quite
pretty back then and we built the goblet
College Baptist Church in the 1870s but
we didn't have any chapel on the campus
except that little thing and she just
thought that was terrible and she said
why don't you have a proper chapel and I
said well I've been waiting we have a
plan from one we made a plan for the
campus in 2001 and there's a chapel on
the plan and I said I've been waiting
for somebody to say you need an
excellent chapel I would like to help
you build it
and she repeated those words back to me
thinking what that means
her name is back there we had to fight
to get that and Jack's but
Christ's Chapel she wanted it to be
called which is of course exactly the
right thing Jack and Joe stand up please
[Applause]
thank you
you'll see some other names on one of
the plaques out there there's not that
many recognitions in this building most
people didn't want it but build a
certain and his family are right there
and people have been so generous you
know and why do they do that same reason
we do what we do here that makes by the
way all of you that makes everyone who
will see the ceremony everyone who will
take joy from this chapel and that will
be millions it means that they are here
today and they are among the builders of
this building the faculty and the
students are crucial because without the
activities that they carry on I argue
better than anywhere on earth how would
anybody think that it was even plausible
that we could ever building like this
and yet because of them in their work
they fit I think you all even those kids
up there I do hope they don't fall off
but
but if they do we can get more
this building has a form it is classical
what does that mean does that mean that
it looks Greek or Roman it turns out
that the innovation of the Greeks and
the Romans was to look beyond their own
things to the things that are right
whatever their source our place of
origin that's not what it means
unlike Duncan strike and my daughter
I've actually paid tuition in
architecture school and and I feel
entitled to speak on the subject
classical architecture I've teased it
out of them they don't by the way
they're reticent about revealing their
secrets they want you to think it's all
just a mystery because it is but they're
like especially Alice he's much worse
than Duncan it has to fit in its place
it has to go with the things that are
around it we have a beautiful building
right over there 1852 some of the most
important things in American history
have happened in there
Frederick Douglass spoke in there the
building points up the ceilings are high
the windows are generous arched at the
top like this this has to fit was that
one of Duncan's innovations because he
he knew all that in a heartbeat in fact
he showed us pictures of some of the new
buildings because he didn't know there
either he's more artfully even that I
think or he didn't know that they were
new and he said boy people who planned
this College they really thought hard
about how to make it work all together
you have to live up to that
responsibility
and later Whelan pointed it out to him I
think that he was talking about two
buildings that were six years old we
were a little cocky about that but it
has two towers because if it just had
one it would have to be much higher than
central hall and that would not be right
so although it's much larger than
central hall it fits here in its place
the materials have to work this is
yellow brick the old thing here
I confess I did have a woman say to me
one time looking at Stroh secreto after
a remodel that she said dr. Anne is that
a green building and I said no ma'am
that building is yellow
that lady was a donor I don't I don't
know if she still is it means more than
proportion even it means it's right
whatever it is that takes to make it
right it has to be like that it's a
classical building it's like what the
Greeks did a bus saying to all of us we
studied that here of course I have one
more cost to name but I'll name it at
the moment we dedicate the building
right now I will say that this ceremony
would not be right if there were not the
right kind of speaker I don't know that
I know another we were talking about how
we would do this and I said you know the
college stands for these four things
we're gonna need somebody who represents
these four things somebody has to have a
character self-effacing courageous
assertive somebody has to have learning
do you know what he's accomplishing it's
breathtaking
I knew he before he got on the court and
I once thanked him for this because what
he's doing is in the ordinary doing of
his work and his joining in verdicts and
his explaining his opinion he is writing
an accurate constitutional history of
the United States and he's showing a way
out of the distortions that have come
upon us for the last three generations
it's just it is breathtaking if you
doubt it read three opinions my favorite
us versus Lopez Missouri versus Jenkins
and the reason McDonald vs Chicago and
they show the way to fix all this so far
as the court can fix it
a learned man it would have to be a man
who loves freedom in the American
constitutional republic this man is the
greatest liver living interpreter of
those things and finally it would have
to be a man of faith somebody who boughs
and humility before God think of those
things together who would be like that
Clarence Thomas
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
feel like quitting while I'm ahead
thank you dr. Arnn
and thank you for inviting my wife and
me to Hillsdale once again it seems like
homecoming we've been here so often on
the campus is magnificent I'm honored to
have this task of speaking to you all
this afternoon or this morning but I
wonder as dr. Arnn was speaking whether
I'm up to that task and I pray that I am
this is a very special occasion 170
fifth anniversary of Hillsdale and the
dedication of this beautiful Chapel
Christ's Chapel is a culmination of
years of generosity planning and hard
work and the end result is at once
stunning and glorious the chapels
enduring Beauty highlights the
transcendence the sovereignty and the
grace of God
it truly illustrates how architectural
design can reflect the character of God
and evoke a sense of reverence for His
Majesty everyone involved in the
financing planning and the construction
of this Chapel should rightly be proud
it is a magnificent accomplishment but
we have gathered here today not just to
admire this beautiful Chapel we are also
here to dedicate it
the word dedicate in this context means
to set apart and consecrate to a deity
or to a sacred purpose to appropriately
dedicate that's this Chapel then it is
worthwhile to reflect on the purposes
for which we are here who is setting
apart this sacred place on a college
campus the primary purpose of a chapel
is to provide a place where man can
enter the presence of God it provides a
sanctuary in which man can withdraw from
the chaos of our world and seek a sacred
stillness for as Elijah learned on Mount
Horeb God so often comes to us not in
the storms not in the earthquakes or
fires of life but in stillness in a
gentle whisper accordingly men and women
have long sought respite from the noise
and commotion of life daily life where
they can be still and know that He is
God where they can seek an inner calm
and a transcendent peace beautiful
chapels such as this one provide that
sacred space for stillness a place for
an encounter with the divine as the
architect of this Chapel has written
when you enter a church it is as if you
are entering through a gateway from the
profane toward the sacred it is
difficult to overstate the significance
of the role that this particular chapel
will play in the life of Hillsdale
College many of life's momentous events
take place in chapels
take weddings for example when a couple
enters into the sacred covenant of
marriage they do so not only before
friends and family but also before
Almighty God when the wedding is held in
chapel the chapel exalts the occasion
and signifies that God Himself is a
witness to the couple's exchange of vows
or reflect on funerals and memorial
services as we grieve the loss of a
friend or family member and reflect on
their lives we also seek comfort hope
and peace conducting that solemn service
in a chapel reminds us that our deepest
needs are met through God who is near to
the brokenhearted the wretched and the
lonely and as we are drawn to reflect on
that eternal life beyond the grave a
sacred space such as this chapel with an
image of the cross that old rugged cross
serves as a poignant testament to the
hope of the resurrection
chapels also provide a space for other
important activities that take place on
a more regular basis for example worship
services will be held in this Chapel if
our highest purpose is to glorify God
what better resource to provide on a
college campus
than a chapel that allows students
faculty administrators staff and
visitors to gather together for worship
and prayer this Chapel also will serve
as a setting for ceremonies and
liturgical concerts allowing all who
gather here to learn together and
celebrate before God and the chapel will
the chapel will be used regularly for
personal prayers of reflection
meditation confession repentance
forgiveness and reconciliation chapels
are particularly important in providing
a place for the burdened for the
brokenhearted and despairing when life
is difficult and seems pointless
we need a safe haven where we can escape
from the storm and find solace chapels
provide that setting they invite us to
draw near to God and to elevate our
thoughts to seek his wisdom to lay down
our burdens at the foot of the cross and
to find that peace that in surpasses all
understanding for here we know we are
standing on holy ground in the words of
a popular gospel hymn when I walked
through the door I sense his presence
and I knew this place this was a place
where love abounds for this is a temple
the god we love abides here oh we are
standing in the presence his presence on
holy ground
this calls to mind Hannah the mother of
the prophet Samuel when she came to the
tabernacle to pray she was Behrend but
longed for a child the Bible describes
her as deeply depressed a woman troubled
in spirit who was experiencing great
anxiety and vexation and weeping
bitterly but Hannah poured out her soul
before the Lord at the tabernacle and
after a time of Prayer and speaking with
the priests her face was no longer sad
she came to the tabernacle in anguish
she left at peace Hannah's story reminds
me of a young woman I saw some years ago
in the church I attend near the court as
an ell saying the Rosary after Mass I
notice her crying her shoulders jerking
rhythmically as she sobbed heavily we
happen to leave the church at the same
time and as we did I asked her if she
was okay
her face streaked with mascara she
answered in a quiet peaceful voice I am
now whatever burden that woman was
carrying when she entered the church she
did not leave with it in the words of
the letter to the Hebrews she drew near
to the throne of grace and she did so in
a church building I have no doubt that
many will enter here burdened and like
Hannah and the young woman leave
unburdened and at peace come to me all
who labor and are heavy-laden I will
give you rest I humbly offer my own
story that is similar like Hannah my
life was changed through prayer at a
time of at a place of worship although I
was raised Catholic and even spent four
years in seminary in my early adult II
doubt years I became greatly
disillusioned with the church and made
the mistake of angrily storming away
impetuousness of youth throughout law
school in the early years of my career I
was self-reliant so I thought and gave
little attention to God but not long
after I joined President Reagan's
administration I was in the midst of one
of the darkest periods of my life I was
in my 30s running a federal agency on
significant public scrutiny and
criticism I had little money I was
raising my young son and I was grieving
the loss of the two most important
people in my life my grandparents life
seemed hopeless
and felt like I had nowhere to turn in
the midst of this hardship and grief God
drew me back to the church and he used a
church building to do it it was during
this period seemingly a raft of Hope
that I began to make daily visits to
local Catholic churches to pray for
wisdom and courage as well as strength
and guidance
unlike the tumultuous world around me
the church building provided a place of
peace a sanctuary from the turmoils of
my life within those walls with God's
help and grace I was able to elevate my
thoughts beyond my circumstances and
self-absorption
and set my mind on things that are above
not on things that are on earth as Saint
Paul wrote in the letter to the
Colossians God used these times of
prayer and meditation to rekindle the
flame of faith in my life I'm a changed
man
today and God began that transformation
in a holy place a sanctuary which like
this Chapel where I could temporarily a
sanctuary much like this Chapel where I
could temporarily leave behind the
onslaught of life's difficulties and
bring my troubles before the Lord God
used this renewed faith to sustain me
and my wife through my confirmation
hearings and we continue to rely daily
on the grace he gives us but there's
nothing unique about this in our lives
for many people chapels and churches
have served as beacons of hope physical
reminders of our need for God and His
grace and the presence of a chapel on a
college campus is particularly important
in fact in this age of popular
iconoclasm building a chapel on a
college campus is all but foreboding the
college years require young people to
make decisions that will affect the rest
of their lives they are exposed to new
ideas new relationships new distractions
and new temptations they need a place
where they can go to be relieved of
their troubles and yet their bearing or
so they're bearing as so much comes at
them so fast by building this Chapel
Hillsdale College has provided that
space where students can come to discern
God's calling to pray through difficult
times and to praise God for His
faithfulness in short Hillsdale College
has recognized the importance of
equipping students not only
intellectually but also spiritually for
the many challenges of life in college
and beyond although a chapel is a place
for many activities it also serves as a
statement about the importance of those
activities the construction of cava
college Chapel in a particular in
particular is a public declaration that
faith and reasons are mutually
reinforcing and in 2019 the construction
of a chapel is a bold act of leadership
at a crucial time in our nation's
history so I would like to briefly
underscore the significant devote
broader significance
of the decision that Hillsdale College
has made in building Christ Chapel
beginning in the early 1900's many elite
private colleges and universities began
to face questions about the continuing
relevance of religious instruction on
campus these questions would have
surprised the founders of those schools
many of which were created in part for
the express purpose of providing
religious instruction but as time went
on and schools moved away from their
religious roots the relevance of
religion to higher education was
increasingly questioned and campus
chapels in particular came to be viewed
as relics of a bygone era with a
completion of Christ Chapel Hillsdale
College has staked out its position in
this debate and its decision serves as
an example for all of us the
construction of so grand a chapel in
2019 does not happen by accident or as
an afterthought Christ's Chapel reflects
the college's conviction that a vibrant
intellectual environment and a strong
Democratic Society are fostered not
hindered by a recognition of the divine
Hillsdale College affirms with the
writer of Proverbs that the fear of the
Lord is the beginning of wisdom and the
knowledge of the Holy One is in sight by
constructing this Chapel the college
upholds the continued importance of its
Christian roots even as it respects the
rights of each person to worship God
according to the dictates of his own
conscience our country was founded on
the view that a correct understanding of
the nature of God and the human person
is critical to preserving the Liberty
that we so enjoy John Adams wrote our
Constitution was made only for moral and
religious people it is wholly inadequate
to the government of any other
he recognized that the preservation of
Liberty is not guaranteed without the
guardrails supplied by religious
conviction popular sovereignty can
devolve into mob rule unmoored
from any conception of objective truth
as a think about our political culture
today I am reminded of Ronald Reagan's
warning that freedom is never more than
one generation away from extinction we
didn't pass it to our children and the
bloodstream the only way they can
inherit the freedom we have we have
known is if we fight for it protect it
defend it and then hand it to them to do
the same each generation is responsible
to both itself and to succeeding
generations for preserving and promoting
the blessings of liberty faith in God
more than anything else
fuels the strength of character and
self-discipline necessary to Abele
discharge that responsibility that is
why I am so encouraged by the
construction of Christ's Chapel
Hillsdale colleges article of articles
of association affirm that inestimable
blessings flow from the prevalence of
civil and religious liberty an
intelligent piety in the land the
college was founded on the belief that
the diffusion of sound learning is
essential to the perpetuity of these
blessings
thus Hillsdale College was founded on
the understanding that the battle to
preserve
and promote freedom in our country will
be waged in the hearts and minds of the
people rather than shrinking from the
battle
Hillsdale is rising to the occasion by
investing in the intellectual and
spiritual development of its students so
they can provide god-honoring leadership
in our country let it be said of them
what was said of David that he served
the counsel of God in his own generation
students faculty administrators and
Friends of Hillsdale but this chap will
be more than just an impressive building
let this Chapel be more than just let
this be let it be a place where people
enter the presence of a majestic God let
it be a house of worship of Prayer of
meditation and of celebration before God
let it be a haven of rest for the weary
a place of healing for the wounded a
place of comfort for the grieving and a
source of hope for this for the
despairing and forgotten let it point to
a day when the dwelling of God will be
with men when God Himself will wipe away
every tear and mend every wound let it
be a place where tomorrow's leaders
discern their callings and grow firm in
their convictions let it stand as a bold
declaration to a watching world that
faith and learning are rightly
understood as complements and that both
are essential to the preservation of the
blessings of liberty above all let this
Chapel equipped and inspire us to honor
God in whatever he calls us to do for as
st. Paul wrote in the letter to the
Romans from him and through him and to
him are all things to him be the glory
forever
then may God bless each of you may God
bless Hillsdale and may God bless this
wonderful country
thank you
[Applause]